[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce programme est diffusé en
audiodescription et cette fois pas juste
pour les malvoyants
assis sur mon fauteuil roulant j'entre
sur scène je m'arrête au centre d'un
papillon rouge
bonsoir tout le monde on vous l'a dit je
m'appelle arthur j'ai 27 ans depuis
quatre jours et je suis ce qu'on appelle
une personne en situation de handicap
j'aime pas me résumer qassam et un taux
que ces cours alors je vais à
l'essentiel
vous savez quoi maintenant que je suis
sur scène façon je fais ce que je fais
donc on va le prendre le temps parce que
si moi même je ne me définis par le
handicap
comment voulez-vous voir autrement je
suis lillois franco américain gay auteur
réalisateur pianiste et j'en passe
bref comme vous j'ai une vie normale
d'ailleurs quand on m'a proposé de
participer à ce taux que je me suis dit
mais moi j'ai pas traverser la manche à
la nage sans bras ni jambes
qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir le
raconter et bah mon sens le handicap est
une simple différence
alors on va essayer d'en parler
différemment pour que d'ici 2030 les
regards changent
d'ailleurs vous savez ce que c'est que
le handicap vous alors on n'est pas à la
télé vous me parlez pas de problème vous
savez ce que c'est que le handicap
oui robin super merci j'ai terminé mi
temps de repartir non plus sérieusement
on sait tous plus ou moins ce que c'est
mais laissez moi quand même vous
rappeler la définition
avant ça vous connaissez peut-être syrie
ou auxquelles google
aujourd'hui je suis avec teddy ok t'es
dit tu peux nous rappeler ce peuple est
la définition mettrait en duel avec sa
voix constitue un handicap au sens de la
loi toute limitation d'activité aux
restrictions de participation à la vie
en société subit dans son environnement
par une personne en raison d'une
altération substantielle durable
définitif d'une ou plusieurs fonctions
physiques sensorielles mentales
cognitives ou psychique d'un
polyhandicap ou d'un trouble de santé
invalidant
parker c'est chaud merci la techno elle
est longue cette définition
mais au moins les complète parce que
contrairement à ce que l'on pense
souvent à handicaper bah c'est pas juste
un gars en fauteuil d'ailleurs petite
devinette
à votre avis quel est le pourcentage des
fauteuils chez les handicapés 40%
qui dit mieux trente pour cent
vingt-cinq ébats dans les chiffres
tenez vous bien seulement 2% cement
fauteuil sacré raccourcir la faute vient
notamment du pictogramme reconnu un
petit peu partout dans le monde
vous savez celui qui montre une
silhouette assis sur un fauteuil pour
symboliser le handicap
ok t'es dit ajoute un nouvel événement
mon agenda pour 2030 je dépose mes pieds
au sol premier rappel prend appui sur
les accoudoirs du fauteuil et me lève
si on veut changer les regards sur le
handicap il faudrait déjà considérer
tous les handicaps
bien sûr je souhaite à personne d'avoir
un jour besoin d'un fauteuil
cette mise en scène là c'était juste
pour vous faire ouvrir les yeux je suis
handicapé certes mais visuel depuis mes
14 ans je suis atteint d'une maladie
dégénérative à la rétine aujourd'hui je
ne vois plus devant moi et mal sur les
côtés je suis mal voyons pas aveugle
enfin pas encore mais la recherche
avance si je vous regarde comme ça à
l'égyptienne de profil je vous distingue
des formes un contraste
mais pour me conformer aux conventions
sociales je vous fait croire que je vous
regarde en face à part un fauteuil
roulant
je ne peux pas conduire une assistante
sur le fauteuil je peux pas lire un
bouquin à moins qu'il n'ait de partage
mais je m'adapte au début j'ai bricolé
ma petite technique pour éviter de
percuter des gens dans la rue sans
jamais montrer ma différence
en gros je faisais mine d'être concentré
sur mon écran de téléphone
en règle générale les gens le voient et
ses cartes tout seul contrairement aux
passants landes à un poteau ses cartes
plus rarement
alors après quatre écrans de téléphones
cassé je me suis avouer que j'avais
besoin d aide
j'ai été formé au déplacement à la règle
pour ça j'ai dû faire le deuil de mon
apparente normalité en portant une canne
blanche
j'ai d'abord détester montrer comme ça
mon handicap au grand jour mais force
est de constater qu'avec ça c'est des
gens qui s'écartent tout seul comme je
ne peux pas lire un plan ou un panneau
dans la rue j'ai été formé aux
déplacements par représentation mentale
c'est très simple quand on ne peut pas
voir il faut savoir il faut visualiser
son trajet pour ne pas se perdre
imaginons de cette salle au supermarché
le plus proche faut prendre tout de
suite à gauche tout droit après deux
croisements la bouche de métro se trouve
sur la place un arrêt et en sortant la
porte du supermarché se trouve de
l'autre côté du boulevard facile on y va
north sur scène
alors on y va lever vous on y va dans le
noir c'est pas si facile hein est ce que
quelqu'un a une petite idée une solution
personnes lumière et bien mesdames et
messieurs laissez moi vous présenter
celle que j'aime à appeler la prunelle
de mes yeux bien ma puce un berger
allemand munies d'un harnais ne rejoint
pas là elle s'appelle lollia bien modèle
wi fi loyat s'allonge me faisant face
elle vous tourne le dos et un peu timide
je la tourne face au public et voilà le
ya même montré son ventre et une petite
gratte avec loyat dans la rue je me
déplace en toute sécurité
le harnais qu'elle porte la barre que je
tiens c'est ce qui me permet de
comprendre ce qu'elle me dit avec le
corps j'aurais adoré vous faire une démo
mais aller se balader dans la rue suivi
par 300 personnes
c'est pas le plus pratique alors si vous
voulez voir quelques images
je posterai s'assure un stade parce
qu'avec le ja on tient compte pour faire
un petit peu de sensibilisation
mais là tout de suite je vais vous
expliquer concrètement ce que c'est que
son boulot dans la rue elle me guide sur
le trottoir elle évite les obstacles
elle s'assied au passage tout et pour me
signaler le danger
elles connaissent à droite à gauche ou
pop au redoux quant au modèle elle
connaît sa droite sa gauche à proximité
elle peut me trouver une bouche de métro
un arrêt de bus ou une porte sur une
façade dont la loya s'est assoupi si en
chemin il y avait eu des travaux loyat
se serait couché pour me dire qu'on ne
peut pas passer
et elle aurait calculer un itinéraire
bis les chiens d'assistance sont de
vrais polytechnicien loyat a changé ma
façon de me déplacer
mais au fond elle a changé ma vie malgré
moi l'as cannes m'a rendu visible mais
loyat nous a rendu remarquable
remarquable parce que quand on double
des gens dans la rue guidés par genre de
petites peluches doués d'intelligence
les gens complimente le fit il
s'intéresse à elle puis au m et en fait
on échange
alors vous ça vous paraît rien mais pour
moi c'est énorme et non parce que
instinctivement l'humain on va vers ce
qu'il connaît et lui ressemble
l'inconnu fait peur et le handicap
donc pour effet d'isoler sociale mais là
le chien devient le vecteur pour
favoriser le lien humain l'animal
nour a en fait plus humain c'est
paradoxal mais tellement génial
d'ailleurs vous allez voir lui moment
n'est pas un paradoxe près c'est fou que
les valides et toujours cette petite
appréhension et n'aillent pas plus
naturellement vers les handicapés
pourtant dans cette salle où derrière
vos écrans
chacun de vous connaît la dépendance
l'incapacité de marché et même
l'incontinence là vous dites quoi un
continent non
et ben si on a tous été bébé même après
neuf mois de grossesse
nous organisons notre cerveau est
inachevée nous naissons prématurée et
comme la vie est un cycle avec
l'allongement de la durée de vie ben on
reviendra tous plus ou moins dépendants
mais c'est pas grave pour 2030 teddy
deuxième rappel n'ayons pas peur du
handicap ou des handicapés parce qu'au
fond tous les humains de son alors
attention je vous en parle avec légèreté
mais au quotidien le handicap c'est
super dur
lâchez-nous dans une ville que l'on ne
connaît pas avec 1% de batterie et tant
qu'à faire
à 9h du mat savez quand les gens pressés
n'ont pas le temps de vous aider dans va
moins se marrer heureusement la plupart
du temps mon chien
la techno mes proches ou des inconnus
dans la rue m'aide à compenser et
j'arrive à vivre en relative autonomie
ça aussi c'est énorme
parce que rappelons nous qu'à l'état de
nature un animal handicapé lui ne survit
pas sélection naturelle darwin parce que
l'humain est un animal handicapés pour
ne pas disparaître
nous sommes protégés les uns les autres
sous forme de sociétés humaines de nos
jours en france la société prothèse bien
les handicapés
c'est une oeuvre collective alors
j'aimerais qu'on s'applaudissent tous
pour ça
oui elle nous protège enfin elle nous
laisse en vie mais au fond elle nous
laisse aussi à la marge ça applaudit
mois on l'a vu le handicap plutôt les
handicaps sont mal connus par les
valides si dans la vie de tous les jours
l'échangé humain permet de casser ces
barrières dans le monde du travail
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué y a qu'à
voir le taux de chômage chez les
handicapés
il est plus de deux fois supérieur à
celui des valides une étude française de
2011 révèle que en majorité les managers
voit les handicapés comme courageux mais
aussi improductif c'est fou ce
stéréotype négatif que l'on colle on
voit le handicap comme une limite
mais à mon sens c'est aussi une
opportunité je suis pas utopiste mais
juste mal voyants je vois pas les choses
telles qu'elles sont alors je les
imagine telles qu'elles seront ça vous
tente qu'on imaginait ensemble la vision
2030 du handicap
allez pour une fois que je peux c'est
moi qui vous guide ça me fait plaisir
les trains ont dû de nouveau ces marches
arthur vous souhaitez vous allez non
t'es dit c'est moi qui gère là on l'a vu
les handicapés sont toujours à la marge
de la société
nous avons collectivement échoué dans
leur pleine intégration
pourtant c'est exactement ce qui va nous
servir à leur réintégration
je m'explique à l'instar d'une
entreprise qui fait appel à des
consultants extérieurs pour solutionner
en interne par son parcours de vie si
différents mais si riche
le handicap à bhl proposera des
solutions innovantes à la société un
jour j'ai vu une interview passionnante
de bertrand piccard vous savez cela rime
pulse
il disait qu'il avait foi en la
transition écologique parce que les
énergies vertes tendent à devenir moins
chers que nos vieilles habitudes
polluantes
10la et terriblement génial terrible
parce qu on comprend que l'homme ne
changera jamais sans pognon mais génial
parce qu'il met en fête le doigt sur le
levier principal du changement d'intérêt
bas pour le handicap c'est pareil si on
veut faire changer les regards
il faut faire comprendre à la société
l'intérêt qu'elle va en tirer
on parlait du monde du travail l'instant
ébats continent actuellement on connaît
trop le management inhumain je dis pas
ça pour toi lauga mais on a un peu
tendance à nous prendre pour des chiens
quand même malheureusement j'en ai fait
les frais mais il y a deux ans gauche à
droite il y a deux ans j'ai eu la chance
de participer à la plus grande master
class en management
j'ai rencontré monsieur thibault blairon
alors si ça vous dit rien c'est
complètement normal parce qu'en fait
c'est juste l'éducateur de loyat aux
chiens guides de paris mais ce qu'il m'a
enseigné m'a mis une énorme claque
contrairement aux humains qui ont besoin
de travailler pour vivre les chiens non
il faut donc les intéressés à travailler
loyat appris en jouant
elle travaille avec plaisir et c'est
pour ça qu'elle me donne le meilleur
pour les chiens guides contrairement une
boîte
il n'y a pas de pression pas de sanction
on préfère valoriser les comportements
positifs
contrairement à certains managers qui
pense avoir mieux faire que leurs
collaborateurs
voyez un peu dans votre vie des exemples
que ça eba chez nous c'est elle qui voit
lui fait confiance et ça l'autonomie
je n'ai dû mettre que le nom loyat et
moi c'est une équipe interdépendantes
gagnant gagnante elle me guide dans la
rue puis moi je l'emmène au parc
ok t'es dit ajoute un nouvel événement
dans mon agenda mais pour demain cette
fois rappelle-moi de fonder avec
d'autres maîtres chiens un cabinet de
formation en management humain
ouais le management humain existe déjà
mais avec des chiens on a en fait une
clé d'entrée
plus simple don plus puissante pour
former les managers ils guideront leurs
collaborateurs pour donner le meilleur
et ainsi produire plus de valeur cette
simple idée rapporte du pognon en
entreprise mais entre bien-être au
travail et accès à l'emploi des
personnes handicapées ont créé en fait
de la valeur pour toute la société
humaine voyez mieux l'intérêt du
handicap
j'imagine certains qui se disent du
management humain avec des chiens non et
ben pourquoi pas parce qu'en fait sans
savoir la société a déjà largement
trouvé son intérêt dans le handicap les
lunettes que vous portez tous pour le
confort mais surtout pour le style en
fait été inventé au xviiie siècle pour
protéger les yeux de personnes atteintes
de maladies telles que la mienne
souvenez vous il ya encore quelques
années
fallait se lever et aller jusqu'au poste
pour changer juste une chaîne
mais pour aider les personnes à mobilité
réduite
un homme un jour inventé un petit
boîtier qu'on utilise tous bien
confortablement installé au fond d'un
canapé
la télécommande idem pour les assistants
vocaux là aussi bien pratique pour
passer un appel au volant sans perdre
quatre points et ben ils ont en fait été
inventé pour rendre la technologie
accessible au mal et non voyants en fait
le handicap est utile à tous mais il
faudrait juste qu'on s'en souvienne ok
t'es dit je m'inspire un peu de kennedy
mais pour 2030
dernier rappel ne vous demandez plus
comment aider un pauvre handicapés mais
demandez vous plutôt comment on dit
capable pourrait vous aider
et merci à tous mes proches qui m'ont
aidé pour ce toc merci à tedx de m'avoir
invité et merci à vous de m'avoir écouté
je m'approprie l'écart et sonia
[Applaudissements]